biden's free fall if this week revealed
anything it is the catastrophic troubles
the biden administration has caused for
itself and the country this iconic image
here could be a metaphor for biden's
entire presidency an executive stumbling
and causing chaos with every step he
takes and it's not just when he's
climbing staircases though a chairlift
couldn't hurt at this stage the biden
policies no matter how well intended are
leading to ruinous ends for the american
people his vaccine mandates coupled with
a bloated welfare state that he means to
grow even more are wiping out jobs today
everyone expected 500 000 new jobs for
the month of september
whoops
194
whoa i see 194
000. that is real low september now
coming in weaker than august which was
revised higher and i think that's the
big number that's the big story here
yeah well biden tried to spin the bad
news this way
the monthly totals bounce around but if
you take a look at the trend it's solid
but when you take a step back and look
at what's happening we're actually
making real progress
no if that's progress i'd hate to see
what failure looks like they're the
worst job numbers of the year we have a
cargo crisis at our ports there's a
10-day backup for ships in the dock at
the port of los angeles because they
can't find people to unload the cargo
but at least women are thriving under
biden's economy right august we saw men
going back to work seven to one the rate
of women and my gosh in these last jobs
numbers women actually lost 26 000 jobs
in the market
and education related jobs are being
destroyed as well business insider
reports not only did local governments
shed a hundred and forty four thousand
jobs but seventeen thousand jobs were
lost in state government education and
nineteen thousand in private education
along with teachers there have been
reports in recent months of shortages
for other jobs related to education this
is what biden's vaccine mandates has
wrought at the same time he ceded
educational policy to the teachers
unions and while they advance radical
curricula and insist kids wear a mask
despite
no scientific evidence
his justice department this week
targeted
concerned parents
you see the teachers unions and school
boards don't like having their decisions
questioned so now the federal government
is partnering with local law enforcement
to police and punish mouthy parents
after all they're not parents they're
maniacs just listen to the media
conservatives manufactured outrage over
masks and history lessons took our
school boards hostage like a bunch of
screaming maniacs is this really about
people being upset about mask mandates
or are there sort of underlying
disruptive forces white nationalists uh
anarchists the greatest number and the
biggest concern that we have are the
threats of violence the coordinated
efforts that we seem to see those videos
that we see are incredibly
almost
scary
scary as demonizing parents worried
about their kids by the way usa today
rightly states there is no proof that
involved concerned parents are a
dangerous threat to school boards and
yelling at bureaucrats trying to teach
your kid
about sexual positions is hardly a hate
crime
it's now clear that parents children and
families have become real targets for
this administration
and on monday biden lifted a trump-era
ban on clinics that refers patients to
abortion or for abortions rather from
receiving federal funding and buried in
the democrats multi-trillion dollar
reconciliation bill is a clause
that quote more than doubles the earned
incomes tax credits marriage penalty for
childless workers giving eligible
couples a compelling reason to avoid
tying the knot the proposed changes
threaten to substantially increase the
breadth and depth of marriage penalties
for families with children as well
aren't strong families and marriages in
the nation's interest
not according to this bill
biden used to stand for families and he
was
moderately pro-life throughout much of
his senatorial career when you compare
the joe biden of the past to the
president today
he appears to have literally lost his
way the staff seems to be running the
show they've even created a little
off-broadway theater next door to the
white house for the president's public
events
i call it mr biden's neighborhood a cozy
safe space for him to make believe them
he doesn't even require a trolley to
take him there though the puppets are
present and accounted for
this is really designed to protect the
president from those uncomfortable press
questions you see
in this setting reporters become
spectators in the dark who are forced to
watch these little stage shows from the
orchestra unlike an east room ceremony
or an oval office spray the press won't
dare yell questions and disrupt the
production before them and once the
staff thinks they've seen enough well
they just usher them out
it's like aladdin on broadway after a
covet scare everybody get out go go go
we're canceling everything
not that any of this has helped biden
once americans hear him without filter
it does not instill confidence
also we've got state leadership here
lieutenant governor julia's here stan
stratton
and the ohio pennsylvania ohio
pennsylvania i'm from pennsylvania
the the the illinois president
of the don harmon and robert reiter
rita
reader reiter rereader chicago
federational labor
and folks
that's how we beat coven 19.
that's how we beat cove in 19.
glad to know the who is taking notes uh
the american people are not stupid
they see this confusion they feel the
prices at the pump and at the grocery
store they see hunter biden's gallery
side grift which we're going to get to
shortly they see the pitiful foreign
policy blunders in afghanistan and
europe and it has taken a toll on biden
a new quinnipiac poll reveals 53 percent
of americans disapprove of his job
performance 53 percent 60 percent of
independence now disapprove of him if
biden continues on this ruinous path he
won't need a pole
he'll need a net